Donna: Something creepy is
going on
We all see it.
Ruben: Woah.
It's a ghost.
Ruben: A ghost... writer?
Ruben: It's not easy
being the new kid.
The menu board says-
-Come together.
Curtis: Ever since you
moved here,
we're seeing these
bizarre messages.
This never happened
at my old school.
I'm pretty sure it's
never happened at any school.
Ruben: Alice's Adventures
in Wonderland.
Chantal: The ghost writer let
the characters out of the book.
Ruben: The Mad Hatter.
Donna: Alice.
Donna: The rabbit.
That's Mr. W. Rabbit to you.
Rabbit: What is this?
What are you doing?
Ugh. Horrifying.
Ruben: Look.
Donna: Moguli,
from the Jungle Book.
Ruben: Why did the ghost writer
release these characters?
Find the book and read it.
That's the only way we're
going to solve this mystery.
Pigeon: Do you have
anything to eat?
Nope.
So now we can
hear animals talking.
Where is my dinner?
I have grown tired of
the cheap kibble.
Donna: Ghosts only hang around
Donna: when they have some sort
of unfinished business
There's something bigger.
A real secret.
Run!
You are quite a small cat.
What I lack in size,
I make up for in charm.
Ghost writer!
Donna: Can you hear us?
Ay!
Hey!
The whole city can.
Super cool.
You have no idea.